who doesn't love a walk through a dark
forest the sight of branches set against
the low moonlight looking like all
manner of dark and twisted claws
reaching out of the night to grab at you
every step brings with it the snap of a
broken twig that practically echoes
around you whenever a breeze rustles the
leaves on the trees you feel like
something might just be following you
moving through the forest towards you it
is easy to get lost in a force at night
after all that's why the children's song
warns us that if you go down to the
woods today you'd better not go alone
the image of a forest in the darkness
has inspired fear for generations from
fireside folk tales telling of wolves
and monsters lurking among the trees to
modern horror games about a tall
faceless man in the suits stalking you
through the woods and then of course
there's scp-060
otherwise known as the infernal occult
skeleton now despite the name as
cp060 is in actual fact a forest or at
least it's a forest to begin with a
picturesque grove of 17 tall white oak
trees spread out across eight acres of
land in rural northeast minnesota it
almost looks like something out of a
tourist brochure a beautiful stretch of
forest sitting under clear skies well
during the daytime anyway if you ever
find yourself hiking through a corner of
minnesotan forest that isn't in any of
the guidebooks then tread carefully you
might just stumble upon the demolished
ruins of a house that used to stand
among the trees out in seclusion and a
word of advice to you if you happen
across this place do not under any
circumstances stop walking for a smoke
break of course thanks to the good folks
at the scp foundation you're unlikely to
ever just wander your way into scp-060
more likely they'll administer you with
amnesics the foundation's patented
memory altering drugs and send you on
your merry way totally oblivious to the
huge hard to miss greenhouses containing
scp-060 beyond those glass walls you
might have caught glimpses of foundation
personnel watering the trees carefully
tending to each
scp-060 specimen maybe you saw them
gathering up leaves and pruning each
tree individually composting every part
of dead plant matter instead of leaving
the white oaks to grow freely and
perhaps you even noticed that not one
member of personnel was carrying a
lighter on their person nor a taser or
so much as a small box of matches
nothing that can start a fire or rather
you would remember seeing all that if
the amnestics hadn't already made you
forget but what's so special about these
trees
why would the scp foundation go to the
extent of housing a collection of white
oaks in greenhouses and meticulously
oversee their growth what is it about
these particular specimens that make
personnel so cautious about fire safety
and why on earth is
scp-060 a collection of trees referred
to by the nickname the infernal occult
skeleton well the answer to all those
questions becomes pretty apparent the
moment any of the
scp-060 oak trees catch fire and
something comes hurtling out of the
forest that something is known as
scp-060
alpha standing at just over two meters
tall the entity takes the form of an
adult human skeleton much more than just
a spooky scary collection of bones
scp-060 alpha is fully animate capable
of moving of its own accord without the
aid of muscles or a nervous system oh
and it also happens to be on fire move
aside ghost rider
scp-060 alpha is engulfed from skull to
toe bones in bright white flames burning
at a temperature of approximately 1500
degrees celsius or almost 3 000 degrees
fahrenheit for reference that's just shy
of the melting point of iron and hot
enough to grant a human being a quick
but agonizingly painful death granted
after a few seconds of that heat your
nerve endings would be scalded so maybe
you wouldn't feel that much pain but
1500 celsius is enough to burn the
moisture right out of your skin melt
your eyeballs and generally fry you to a
crisp in a matter of minutes if not
seconds good thing
scp-060 alpha isn't known for being
highly aggressive and hostile oh wait it
is ah
not good upon manifestation the burning
skeleton will attempt to do as much
damage as possible and usually to
whoever is closest it can appear at any
time and after as little as 20 grams
worth of one of the scp-060 trees is
burned as if being actively hostile and
burning hot enough to reshape metal
wasn't bad enough
scp-060-alpha has also shown itself to
be fiercely intelligent the entity seems
to retain knowledge whenever it
manifests and has gained a growing
familiarity with the layout of the
foundation site that contains the
scp-060 oaks the infernal occult
skeleton's methods of attack tend to
include throwing its entire body at
flammable materials however it will
avoid causing any damage to specimens of
scp-060
the skeletal entity can run at speeds up
to 50 miles per hour now that's almost
the same speed as a gazelle just
picturing anything traveling towards you
at that speed is horrifying let alone
something headed straight for you at
gazelle levels of speed while also on
fire it is this combination of speed and
heat that means
scp-060 alpha poses such a threat to
anyone close whenever it appears if left
unchecked the entity could easily cause
colossal and widespread forest fires and
property damage
interestingly any areas that scp-060
alpha does burn with its flames will
start to yield saplings of the
scp-060 oaks around six weeks after the
fire has stopped the foundation doesn't
allow these saplings to grow to full
size and instead pulls them from the
ground and disposes of them composting
the saplings to feed the other
scp-060 specimens luckily the biggest
strength of scp-060 alpha its flames
also happens to be its greatest weakness
it is possible to fight the fires of the
infernal occult skeleton by dowsing it
with water or any other materials
capable of dousing flames whether it's
sand or foam from a fire extinguisher of
course this is a lot hotter and harder
to put out than any ordinary smaller
scale fire but despite being a difficult
task it is not impossible about 500
liters of water should do the trick if
you've got a big enough bucket nearby
after that
scp-060 alpha will be weakened gradually
collapsing and turning into dust however
if another part of an scp-060 tree is
burned and the entity reappears it is
believed that this will be the same
infernal occult skeleton rather than a
new version of the bone-burning being so
we have a grove of oak trees that
manifest a flaming skeleton if they are
ever burned maybe that's not the
weirdest thing you'd see in a minnesotan
forest but wait there's something else
cast your mind back a few minutes and
you'll remember that we mentioned some
ruins the remains of a demolished house
that used to stand secluded among the
scp-060 white oak trees knowing that the
infernal occult skeleton can appear from
the oaks might make it obvious what
happened to this house but there's still
a story to be told here the house's
owner was a man by the name of jonathan
corhill now jonathan was something of an
odd man considered a bit of an eccentric
to some he preferred to spend his time
in solitude alone with his own thoughts
for company rather than mingling among
the rest of the world even his own
family noticed that mr corhill was
drifting away from them becoming a more
bitter nihilistic person in his old age
and choosing isolation over human
connection now sure loneliness doesn't
hold much appeal to everyone but
sometimes there are people who just
prefer being alone that might be what
drew jonathan corhill to a secluded
little house in the forests of minnesota
somewhere no one would bother him for
the most part the rest of the core hill
family adjusted to their eccentric
relatives behavior jonathan would have
rarely accepted visitors to his house in
the forest but he still kept in contact
with those who he'd been close with most
notably he'd regularly share phone calls
with his brother one christopher corhill
that is until something seemed to change
unexpectedly in the year 1996 on one of
their calls jonathan outright told
christopher to never contact him again
severing any ties with any remaining
family members and friends in the
outside world jonathan cut everyone off
living within his own bubble where he
could immerse himself in his unusual
interests according to christopher his
brother had seemed otherwise normal up
until a certain phone conversation but
jonathan had become obsessed with the
occult specifically he had embroiled
himself in the history of the victorian
era and certain supernatural practices
that had been undertaken in that time
period now whether christopher honored
his brother's wish to sever ties is
unknown a mail carrier would visit
jonathan's home in the woods not long
after their phone call maybe among the
envelopes this courier was delivering
what could have been a letter from
christopher or other members of the core
hill family begging their estranged
relative to come back to the world you
see even people who claim to prefer
being on their own sometimes need human
interaction talking to people and being
in the presence of friends and family
are hugely important factors in
maintaining a positive state of mental
health but what happens when someone
rejects that entirely and instead
becomes lost in their obsessive study of
the occult while the mail carrier was
the first to find out arriving at
jonathan corhill's woodland house the
courier found the place looking almost
skeletal a shell of the building that
had once stood in the forest according
to the locals the carrier had been sent
to deliver a notice to mr corhill
explaining that his house was being
foreclosed but it seemed someone or
something had beaten them to it a fire
had spread from the house's fireplace
quickly engulfing the entire structure
presumably with jonathan still inside it
wasn't until later that very same year
that jonathan corhill was officially
reported as a missing person case with
the local authorities any search that
was undertaken in an attempt to find him
uncovered next to no evidence of his
whereabouts to this day nobody knows for
certain if jonathan corhill is dead or
alive his whereabouts are unknown on the
surface it might be easy to make the
assumption that the infernal occult
skeleton reduced the reclusive old man
to nothing more than a cinder it
definitely seems plausible that jonathan
collecting firewood to keep himself warm
in his isolation accidentally chopped
down part of an
scp-060 oak put it in his fireplace and
called forth the vengeful flaming bones
but perhaps we shouldn't be so certain
after all core hill's house wasn't
entirely burned down despite the entity
normally trying to cause as much damage
as possible whenever it appears and on
top of that no human remains were found
in the house and the skeleton of
scp-060 alpha had to have come from
somewhere right
scp-060 offers a few warnings and not
just about the dangers of traveling
through the forest alone the appearance
of the flaming skeleton whenever the
scp-060 white oaks are burned could
serve as a reminder that we need to be
villagent in protecting the forests of
this world trees are one of our few
sustainable resources but for every one
we cut down or that catches fire it
takes years to regrow a replacement and
perhaps the third and final warning of
the infernal occult skeleton is simply
don't play with matches especially
around trees otherwise you might get
burned now go check out the plane that
never was scp-787
and scp-1440 the old man that kills all
living things he touches for more
morbidly fascinating scps